[Music]
and ask him astronaut news submitted by
smelly powder here are 15 of the most
interesting responses by a NASA
astronaut who hosted and asked me
anything on reddit why say NASA
astronaut astronaut NASA astronaut
I love AMAs I keep saying gonna do it
you should but I always just answer
questions on my YouTube I'm so
interested because astronauts are so
cool man I remember we talked about just
about now to Khalif that that one school
in Pasadena yeah Caltech Caltech has a
lot of astronauts that [ __ ] graduate
from there you know that's just freaking
amazing I didn't know how how affluent
like Caltech is how dope it is you got
to be like a genius physically fit
person to be astronaut oh no idea that
shit's amazing y'all know how to fly oh
there's all kinds of crazy requirements
I wanted to be an astronaut since I was
a kid and then when I first got carsick
it killed all my dreams it was like
people like that who go to schools like
that I have like a lot of like
admiration for them from a distance but
I never want to meet them in person
because I think they're gonna piss me
off
with the [ __ ] that they say you know I'm
saying cuz they're always like those
people that have to correct everything
that you say
so I want to admire them from a distance
it's like a girl on Instagram if you
masturbate to her in your own privacy
it's okay but when you meet them it
disappears because you see hair on her
arm yeah you know what's ironic there's
this guy at my old unit his name was
Nancy corporal Huntington any graduate
from Cal Tech yeah first name is Mack
score no that's his rank he's their
child [ __ ] Lance Corporal Lance
Corporal yeah but he's he's like a
genius right he went to contact and I've
asked him a bunch of questions before
and I was literally found Victorian
middle school valedictorian of a high
school got recorded - not recruited to a
very special high school became valley
torn there then some Cal Tech is
prematures a collection of argot
Orient's man he's a genius but he has
like the most
it is common sense ever that his
nickname is actually rocks get Lance
Corporal rocks over here because he's
dumb as rocks so it's just crazy that
once your brain operates at a certain
level the normal stuff you you don't
know how to it's like like social
interactions like sometimes they they
lack because we know somebody who was
like he did like DP work or something
like he's very smart very in tune with
like knowing facts about things but it
on a social scale oh yeah [ __ ] stupid
it would be like what say just water
right and then I listen she's rock and
I'm like I'm kind of thirsty and this
was this plug them down chugging away
for any just can't put two and two
together stuff like that when you give
them like a crazy like no that's just
because it's people its people give him
orders thinking that okay this is the
hoarder and thinking that he'll know
what to do but I carry a to Z but the e
only does just that one thing and all
the other thing I've always not way get
the HMMWV ready we needed to go on this
mission right and so you bring it here
but like let's say the front windshield
is completely covered in dirt you
probably want to wipe that off before
you give it to someone that needs to
drive it but you just like leaves it or
something like that like there's no life
or social skills because their brain is
so focused and about one thing that's
why don't give a [ __ ] about resume when
I hire people hmm
imma be applying for barbell soon
another company and lie about all my
feats and I was like well I'd end up
about 400 pounds starting off on a
really bad day so let's just start with
that I've been doing cardio and kill
aesthetics and I do various yeah
emotions and stuff so this astronaut he
was all doing scott kelly cool oh he
actually has a twin who's also an
astronaut what that's a wonderful family
holy [ __ ] what kind of brains were those
enough and the jeans are amazing yeah
that was smart kids Wow so Scott
Scott has the record for the longest
time and space how long that he spend in
space it's like more than 500 days but
not at one pad that number is not
important he's been up there for a long
time yeah
he retired now yes so he went to space a
lot of times a lot of time and then he's
like ask me anything and then he is
actually very active on his Twitter in
like social media he thinks because he's
retired he's bored
no even when he was up in space like he
was really between space yeah he's like
right next to the satellites so he
better have the best reception 15 bars
on your phone dude sighs Ben can hear me
now sorry ridiculous the space that was
next to us that and I couldn't get
reception I'd be [ __ ] pissed yeah you
call customer service one space Verizon
well [ __ ] I'm right next to your
satellite anyways I'm sure I'm gonna
read to you guys there's 15 of the most
interesting questions that he answered
this article here I use Toby this is
imagine if you go to a bar and girls
like so what do you do for a living
astronaut that's [ __ ] sick to be able
to say that what do you do I'm like
Vegas top secret [ __ ] astronaut would
get a [ __ ] wet though no yeah you know
what but if I was a girl like Bobby like
all astronaut that means you're gonna be
gone for a long time and I might have to
cheat on you like [ __ ]
are those face pants you're wearing yeah
ass is out of the question so curious
hey hey can I go into your black hole
there you go I'm talking about their
mouth China oh that's cool too oh I mean
can I slide into that Saturn blast-off
you know he just comes and if he does it
if he comes inside with no condom
houston we have a problem I got the
spacesuit at home I can wear it for you
oh this is actually I still want to hear
the questions he count down before he
goes in the bush doesn't wanna get game
right I got mad game I want to not learn
about [ __ ] slices and Hart wants to
hear that beat goes up and affect the
rocket okay go alright so the first
question here it says what do you think
is the biggest misconception that people
have about astronauts he answered that
they were always the smartest kid in the
class and I was not whoo all right next
question how long does it take to get
used to looking at Earth and realizing
you're not on it what did it feel like
yeah that's weird
yeah cuz when I watched Google Earth
thing when it spins and I pretended on
my astronaut idea I feel so lonely are
you oh my god that's a good turn in the
dark side that's so funny you just jump
on Google Earth you click it on and all
his friends right behind I'm just doing
that I like [ __ ] miss you guys
[Laughter]
all right well his answer to that one
weird is that his life but just think it
look goes in here brain is very idea
number one things you're always telling
like I want to live in your brief yeah I
could only be there for ten minutes and
I'd be like [ __ ] like the [ __ ]
incentives are all [ __ ] bloodshot as
[ __ ] you're drooling out of your mouth
huh it's too much she grows a beard so
myself
that question he said instantly you just
had the right of your life and you know
you are not on earth anymore it's
inspiring that's amazing dude next
question what does the ISS smell like
the International Space Station Casey
guys no no rubber and metal are there
any are there ever any issues regarding
smells and if so how do you go about
solving them answer we store our garbage
on board for a long period of time so
sometimes it can get smelly in general
though it's not an unpleasant smell on
board oh itself has a very unique smell
kind of like burning metal space smells
like burning that question says how do
you know how space yeah like he said
when a volume was previously at vacuum
like after a spacewalk or a resupply
ship arriving when you open the hatch
you can smell it
that's cool that is interesting never
thought about that all these natural
elements no oxygen and we need oxygen
because I was thinking that they were
just gonna throw the garbage into space
yeah like the movies they'd get the
garbage and they bring it back to earth
you know one thing is throw it up with a
bird of the ozone I mean there's a
[ __ ] black hole there's a radial I
should up there with a lot of satellites
that they don't use in the Rockets
because the ozone layer protects us from
those little flecks of rocks right those
little [ __ ] meter they burn in the
atmosphere or the ozone or some [ __ ]
[ __ ] so why can't you still garbage
there but that doesn't mean that they're
coming to earth to go through the ozone
layer it's a burden they're just
floating around out there no I thought
that's what it was for though to protect
us from all the little flecks of [ __ ]
yeah
just like like the air pollution and the
gases and [ __ ] is just stuck right there
you guys watch in the movies there's
that layer that when they go through it
burns [ __ ] up in the atmosphere that's a
speed all right clearly you guys don't
know [ __ ] I'm gonna read one more
question and then you guys can check out
the rest of the questions and the link
in the description so yeah is the last
question I'm gonna read
how has your space experience changed
your outlook slash believes in like oh
yeah he said having a good understanding
of the size of the universe I find it
hard to believe that there's not life
out there
oh yeah having said that I don't think
the aliens stopped visiting earth once
everyone got a camera in their pocket
dude Joe he just answered your question
because there's a lot of UFOs but then
the beings that control them people
never talk about them you know what I
think though I think we're the aliens
hey guys thanks for watching that last
episode did you love it yes you did so
don't forget to subscribe this is first
time you're here we've upload every
single day so don't miss an upload now
to watch more episodes check them out ok
[Music]